what's going on guys we're coming at you
with a bonus episode today because
Marvel a Dano we're surprised us with
the delicious free Thanksgiving morsel
the first Captain America civil war
trailer we called all the experts and
they're all out of town for Thanksgiving
so the only folks left are good friends
from screen junkies Spencer Gilbert
thanks for being here buddy
hi he'll have nowhere else to be Dan
Merle hi how this is gonna be a half day
but oh well before we dive into what was
in the trailer Dan you saw footage from
d23 the big Disney event yeah a few
months ago they put out what looked like
a full cut trailer for Civil War at d23
and so when I heard that there was a new
trailer coming out I just expected it
would be either what we already saw or a
cut-down version of what we saw at d23
and it wasn't at all this was almost all
new stuff kind of surprisingly it was a
completely different tone like this was
a very kind of dark serious trailer d23
had some of that but it also had some
humor and had some more laugh lines it
had a cameo from a character that I
won't spoil here if you want to go find
out who it was you can probably find out
online sure but that was a very humorous
scene so it was it was kind of more of
the Avengers tone that were used to
whereas this was more of the tone of the
first Ultron trailer that we saw what
would you think of overall tone they put
forth here well that's what I love
Captain America Winter Soldier is one of
my favorite superhero movies of all time
and you just know the character is in
good hands with the Russo brothers they
seem to really get that in these movies
you don't need to throw every single
superhero at the wall and see what
sticks you need a good character at the
center of it where the plot can flow
naturally from that character and from
who you've established and everything I
saw in that trailer reinforces it it
really doubled down on selling it as a
Captain America movie because a lot of
people have said like oh well this is
just Avengers 3 this isn't a Captain
America movie and like Bucky and Winter
Soldier and that storyline was prevalent
it was first and foremost and I really
sold me more than I was expecting on yes
it's Civil War but this is Captain
America's story I'm so happy that they
did not have the giant you know whatever
shot of all of the heroes on each side
coming together for one big punch like
they're not just trying to make this
dense oh there's so much going on this
is a story of a quasi love triangle
between
people with a lot of punching even
though they didn't have that glory shot
of the two sides about to engage and
then BAM the title comes up we saw
opposing forces awesome beatdown that's
my favorite moment the trailer is the
shield pass from Bucky to cap oh do
knock and you got to feel like Iron
Man's holding back at that point can you
just like detonate both of them with a
snap of a finger but it's also you have
to remember that these are friends who
are fighting so the Iron Man doesn't
want to just obliterate them yes it's
people that are opposing each other but
they don't want to kill each other they
just have what I assume to be
ideological differences and we saw kind
of some of the framework of that with
Thunderbolt Ross who's back for the
first time since Incredible Hulk and
then that brief shot of the sokovia
accords well we have the wild card of
Black Panther who knows what he wants to
do these people we did see a shot of cap
chasing Black Panther and so I think it
would be safe to assume that he's
probably on Tony's side I don't know in
the end the Civil War storyline he was
kind of a neutral for a while and then
he chose a side I'm shocked that ant-man
is not in this trailer I thought he
might be on anyone's Lisa he could beat
any of the shots we sent but given that
the post-credits scene for ant-man was
the first scene from this trailer you'd
think there'd be a direct continuity and
you would see him pop up at some point
just crack a joke grow small do
something but I think that also might be
part of like I said this first trailer
is very cap centric so I feel like it
seemed like Marvel's being very
conscious of let's sell audiences first
on Captain America Bucky and then
probably and the second one I'm sure
we'll probably see the other characters
ant-man but I did seem like they wanted
to really focus on this is a Captain
America movie no Spidey which is strange
because he's the center of the comic
book storyline it all centers around
spider-man and his signing up or not
revealing his identity to the world but
nothing I wouldn't mind if they chewed
spider-man like Luke Skywalker for this
movie you just don't see him in the
trailers you save that wrong save that
reveal for the movie hashtag where's
Peter hashtag where's Peter yeah there
you go start it right now uh also
conspicuous by his absence potential
villain Baron Zemo alright yeah right I
just don't know where he's gonna fit
yeah where is he gonna fit in this
narrative I mean they're in Zemo yeah
there's so much going on Spencer you
actually
and I didn't notice that you caught
another villain in the trail that I
didn't even see
oh yeah crossbones them back yeah he's
got there's a little guy leading some
troops it's got the X on his chest you
know doing some pointing he's back he's
at the burns of healed is there anything
else that you noticed that feels
distinctly different from the comic or
surprising a lot of people are expecting
a straight adaptation of the Civil War
comics so they're expecting the
superhero Registration Act they're
expecting things to go exactly as they
want in the comic and I that's not gonna
happen
Marvel's never done that Marvel's never
just done a straight up more forward
adaptation I think they're taking the
general idea of Civil War and fitting it
into the MCU yeah I think it seems like
they are picking and choosing cuz even
the comic has a different inciting
incident they're like low level
superheroes filming like a reality show
that goes horribly awry and that just
seems like it wouldn't fit into the
Marvel Universe that's been created the
comic book I've read that one yeah it's
like it's a great premise maybe not the
best execution I think that you can
actually get better than that comic can
I ask a crazy question more excited for
Batman V Superman or Captain America
Civil War
I'm more excited for Batman V Superman
um Batman V Superman could be the best
or the worst movie that comes out this
year it's got the highest ceiling and
the lowest basement for me of course
it'll probably just end up being good
like most movies they're fine don't just
settle Spencer did this one I've already
settled like Russo brothers Captain
America I know I'm in good hands Batman
V Superman it looks nuts and I can't
wait I'm equally excited for both it's
not a 50/50 thing for me but if you can
ask me which one of I'm more curious to
see it's Batman versus Superman because
like like we pointed out we've seen the
Avengers fight each other they do it in
every movie and I'm sure this will be a
great movie but I hope it will but
Batman V Superman I'm very very curious
to see and I am I'm very hopeful what
I've seen looks great looks awesome yeah
yeah let's see how the other side
handles punching each other yeah I wish
that they'd kept him on the same day I
was a civil war invalid mr. Batman we're
still open on the same day we would have
gone to Batman that would be incredible
I would have gone to see Batman first
mm-hmm there you have it we all really
dug the trailer and we're even that much
more pumped for Captain America Civil
War
what did you think of it what was your
favorite part of the trailer let us know
in the comments section below and don't
forget to tune in tomorrow for a special
Thanksgiving Day screen junkies episode
want to thank Spencer Gilbert Spencer
what do you think before friends family
C and Creed tonight it's all good oh
yeah dan yeah I'm pretty thankful for
hopefully seeing Creed tonight too
because I hear it's great I can't wait
to see Creed I'm thankful for the pecan
pie I'm gonna eat tomorrow I'm thankful
for you guys for tuning in ah thanks for
watching
hit us all up on Twitter bye bye is Jar
Jar like a dark genius of these movies
if this was true and you found out that
Jar Jar Binks was a villain inhabitance
in the force awakens in a month from now
riots